hey man thank you you gave I eat these
noodles Kara that's fine so how's the
social life you making any friends if
I'm gonna transfer making friends seems
like kind of a waste of time don't you
think
no well try I'm trying I don't want to
be here very much longer mom I can enjoy
myself when I get to Harvard well you
can already get into schools like UCLA
with a 1350 yeah but the UM the Ivy
League's take 14 50s and above right but
it's just taking the test like seven
times feels pretty obsessive most of our
students only take it around three to
four times yeah okay um I I think I can
do better than a 1350 do you think that
yeah no yeah of course you can are you
doing anything further playing
basketball are you doing okay I'm fine
you're not too stressed out no I'm not
too stressed out
[Music]
hmm what's tomorrow
oh I'm taking the SATs Oh Errol no I'm
good I'm actually I'm trying to kinda
conk out early it was the look III know
it's Halloween but would you mind
keeping it down when you come in later
tonight oh yeah I'm getting up hyper
early tomorrow to get in line gets mania
tickets so I'm kind of early oh well
that's all like all of my problems so
congrats I guess I'll go to bed
take care dude good luck thank you enjoy
enjoy Enya oh oh oh oh Harvey um well
I'm here Oh your checks
oh uh yeah I don't know I don't have a
pen
oh well I got a pen I don't have my
checks a comment they're coming in the
mail but you know how long it takes can
government system Express but uh great
okay well I guess I'll check you later
check you later oh nice dude nice like
that down
[Music]
[Music]
bring your awareness to your breathing
[Music]
three four to Alvarado Street services
emergency hey hey
young Woody Allen that's good I like
that Thanks
would you mind turning the music down
just Ted just a little it's a Halloween
party dude like I know I know I'm sorry
about 11:00 I have a really big test
tomorrow and I was you know I'm sorry
it's not my party if you want to come in
and talk to somebody you're welcome to
but I'm not gonna go in there is no
donors somewhere no I just put my step
bike okay what's your name
okay oh my gosh
if you get this message just like keep
the music down and have a wonderful
Halloween okay thank you bye
[Music]
[Music]
sorry
[Applause]
hi and I live next door can you give me
in there sorry to bother you um we can
hear your music right now can okay could
you like turn your music down just like
a little bit yes I was like a big test
tomorrow okay
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
Hey
my god is this party amazing as a yellow
chest
see you later
[Music]
[Music]
students with temporary medical
conditions must apply for postponement a
minimum of three days in advance of
their commute my test is in two hours
I'm sorry would you like to reschedule
to next February no my applications are
due in January I need I need my scores
in I'm sorry there's really nothing I
can do that party was a riot last night
I slept through India you're two months
late on your rent I need you to pay yeah
go to the next week I need you to pay
now I'm on the middle of a program dude
what the [ __ ]
who's gonna hear it alsa hmm so why are
you being like this because I'm a [ __ ]
I've taken the SATs seven times now
right okay
yeah do you know what it takes to get
into an Ivy League school mmm at least a
1500 yeah I mean I know I should be
grateful for the other oh my god you're
gonna get into a fantastic school you're
like a brain mmm thank you so you don't
get it oh poor baby he's not gonna maybe
get into Stanford if you're a [ __ ]
what does that make me I didn't mean it
like that yeah I know but look you don't
Kanye West Kanye West is a fantastic
producer okay rapper
I understand all his lyrics but that
dude works so hard he's just like always
in the studio ripping up fat beats that
dude does not give a [ __ ] so we should
try to change in your perspective work
hard
yeah but care less
[Music]
yeah
look I'm gonna go to my buddy's house
I'm gonna get 600 bucks deducting 200
for that TV it's kind F so you know but
I'll have the rest of a couple of weeks
in the meantime if you want to you can
smash a couple more of my things you
know I get to choose them though this
time yeah I can do that I am so sorry
don't worry
I shouldn't be she would eat more
anyways you gonna be okay yeah
carefree so carefree feels strong
[Music]
I'm carefree
so carefree I wonder why
[Music]
the hostess
[Music]
these are looking out
my whole tree
to
[Music]